STEVE: APPARENTLY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION FACING MOUNTING
PRESSURE OVER ITS BORDER POLICY
INCLUDING A NEW PLAN TO PAY OUT
TO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
PROPOSED PLAN WOULD REPORTEDLY
SEND 450 MILLION -- THAT'S WRONG
IT SHOULD SAY 450,000 TAXPAYER
DOLLARS PER PERSON TO FAMILIES
WHO WERE SEPARATED AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
HERE TO REACT HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE MEMBER AND AUTHOR OF
THE UPCOMING BOOK "DO WHAT YOU
SAID YOU WOULD DO" FIGHTING FOR
FREEDOM IN THE SWAMP CONGRESSMAN
JIM JORDAN.
GOOD GOOD MORNING TO YOU
RECOMMENDATION GOOD TO BE WITH
YOU,.
STEVE: STEVE THE ADMINISTRATION
CONSIDERING PAYING AT LEAST A
MILLION DOLLARS PER FAMILY TO
THESE MIGRANT FAMILIES WHO WERE
IMPACTED BY PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
ZERO TOLERANCE POLICY AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER WHERE WHEN A
FAMILY UNIT WAS TAKEN INTO
CUSTODY WITH THE KIDS SOME OF
THEM GOT SEPARATED PERMANENTLY.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, THINK ABOUT THIS, YOU
ARE GOING TO PAY PEOPLE HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS WHO BROKE THE
LAW AT THE SAME TIME THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS GETTING READY
TO RAISE TAXES ON THE
HARDWORKING FAMILIES OF THIS
COUNTRY.
IT MAKES ABSOLUTELY NO SENSE.
AND YOU KNOW, I THINK ABOUT
THIS.
FIRST YOU BREAK THE LAW YOU GET
AMNESTY WITH DEMOCRATS NOW THEY
ARE GOING TO PAY YOU FOR
BREAKING THE LAW.
YOU THINK WE HAVE A PROBLEM IN A
CARAVAN COMING TOWARDS THE
BORDER NOW AND WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS,
WAIT UNTIL THE WORD GETS OUT
THAT YOU ACTUALLY GET PAID FOR
BREAKING THE LAW TO COME INTO
OUR COUNTRY.
ONE OF THE MANY STUPID POLICIES
FROM THIS ADMINISTRATION.
STEVE: SURE, WHEN THE WORD GOES
OUT NOT ONLY, YOU KNOW, IS JOE
BIDEN SAYING COME ON OR RATHER
OFFICIALLY DON'T COME BUT COME
ON.
>> YEAH.
STEVE: AND YOUR FAMILY WILL GET
A MILLION DOLLARS IF INVOLVED IN
THIS.
THAT WILL BE CRAZY.
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU, JIM.
APPARENTLY ACCORDING TO THE
"WALL STREET JOURNAL."
THERE IS LIKE A DOZEN BIG LAW
FIRMS WHO ARE NEGOTIATING WITH
THE GOVERNMENT ON BEHALF OF
THESE MIGRANT FAMILIES.
>> YEAH.
STEVE: HOW MUCH DO YOU THINK THE
LAWYERS ARE GOING TO GET IF THE
AVERAGE FAMILY GETS A MILLION
BUCKS THE LAWYERS WILL GET AT
LEAST HALF OF IT.
>> YEAH.
THEY ALWAYS GET A BIG TAKE.
AND, AGAIN, SO THE AMERICAN
TAXPAYERS, THEIR TAXES ARE
GETTING READY GO UP.
LET'S HOPE IT DOESN'T HAPPEN AND
THEY DON'T PASS THIS CRAZY
PACKAGE.
THAT'S WHAT DEMOCRATS WANT TO
DO.
RAISE YOUR TAXES.
MEANWHILE, PAY LAW FIRMS A BUNCH
OF MONEY FOR PEOPLE WHO BROKE
THE LAW TO GET HERE.
IT MAKES ABSOLUTELY NO SENSE.
AND THAT'S ON TOP OF WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN.
REMEMBER.
EVERY SINGLE MONTH FOR SIX
MONTHS IN A ROW, ILLEGAL
ENCOUNTERS ON THE BORDER WENT
UP.
MARCH WAS THE HIGHEST UNTIL JUNE
ACROSS OUR BORDER.
>> THIS IS THE SITUATION AND OH
NOW WE ARE GOING GIVE YOU MONEY
TO DO IT.
MAKES NO SENSE.
STEVE: MEANWHILE, TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S RACE IN
THE COMMONWEALTH OF VIRGINIA
WHERE RIGHT NOW ACCORDING TO THE
POLLS, FOX NEWS POLL, GLENN
YOUNGKIN IS WAY AHEAD OF TERRY
McAULIFFE.
>> YEAH.
STEVE: LESS THAN A WEEK TO GO.
WE HAD THE STORY OUT YESTERDAY
THAT APPARENTLY TERRY
McAULIFFE, HERE IN THE 11TH
HOUR, PAID A LAWYER BY THE NAME
OF MARC ELIAS, HE USED TO BE
WITH PERKINS COIE WHICH HAS BEEN
ALIGNED, THEY ARE THE PEOPLE WHO
WERE INVOLVED IN THE STEELE
DOSSIER ANY HIRED HIM $60,000 ON
THE McAULIFFE SIDE.
FOX NEWS REACHES OUT FOR A
COMMENT AND I GUESS THE
McAULIFFE CAMPAIGN PERSON HIT
THE WRONG BUTTON AND INSTEAD OF
RESPONDING, THEY SAID CAN WE TRY
TO KILL THIS?
WHICH APPARENTLY THEY DIDN'T
WANT THAT STORY OUT THERE.
>> YEAH.
THEY DIDN'T WANT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO KNOW THEY HIRED THIS
DIRTY TRICKSTER LAWYER FOR THE
DEMOCRATS WHO HAPPENED TO HAVE
BEEN THE PARTNER FOR THE GUY
JOHN DURHAM JUST INDICTED
MICHAEL SUSSMANN.
THESE ARE THE GUYS AT PERKINS PS
COIE WENT AFTER PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN.
I CAN SEE WHY THEY DIDN'T WANT
THE STORY OUT THERE.
IT SHOULDN'T SURPRISE US.
TERRY McAULIFFE HIS NAME IS
TERRY McAULIFFE CLINTON.
HE HAS BEEN ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CLINTONS FOREVER.
IT SHOULDN'T SURPRISE US HE IS
USING THEIR LAWYER TO TRY TO
PLAY THE SAME KIND OF GAMES AND
GO AFTER GLENN YOUNGKIN.
STEVE: JIM, 15-SECOND ANSWER.
WHY IS GLENN YOUNGKIN WINNING?
>> YEAH, BECAUSE BECAUSE MOMS
AND DADS ACTUALLY KNOW MORE
ABOUT THEIR KID'S EDUCATION.
THIS IDEA THAT GOVERNMENT KNOWS
MORE THAN A PARENT OR MOM OR DAD
THAT OIVEDZ PEOPLE.
IT SHOULD.
THEY SAID ENOUGH OF THIS
BOLOGNA.
WE WILL PUT SOMEBODY IN OFFICE
WHO RESPECTS US.
STEVE: THANK YOU, SIR FOR
JOINING US LIVE.
>> THANK YOU.